politics
is being set at levels much higher than
the US Congress I think this is why
people have an increased focus on the
world economic forum
I think this is why a lot of the
political debate in recent years has not
been about the left versus the right or
the Democrats versus the Republicans a
lot of the political debate in the last
six or seven years has been about the
nationalists or the Patriots versus the
globalists that's a that's a big shift
and you are seeing globalist political
power represented in its clearest
expression just this coming week at
Davos at the world economic Forum most
people don't know what the world
economic forum is the world economic
forum is this
non-profit organization that was founded
in 1971 by Klaus Schwab who looks and
sounds like a James Bond villain and
acts like one too but it's not a
governmental body exactly
and it's not a private organization
exactly
the world economic forum
gets Government funding from governments
all over the world the world economic
Forum hosts tons of heads of state 53 I
think this year 52 heads of state
are participating in the annual meeting
of the world economic forum
52 heads of state that's a massive
number and nearly 300 government
ministers are going to be participating
in the world economic forum and what is
the purpose of the form the purpose of
the Forum is to bring together
the public sphere and the private sphere
all over the world
exactly what we've been talking about in
this show to bring together the politics
and the culture
and to pull it all together
so that when we decide in Davos that
climate change is a really big problem
you know after we fly in on our I think
at the current moment it's something
like 1500 private jets it might be more
like 2500 private jets fly into Davos
and we're really worried
about how you you Hoy polloi are using
gas stoves that's very bad for the
environment I was reading an article
about it on my private jet flying into
my Swiss mountain town in Davos it's
very bad and so what we need to do is
not only pressure the governments to
take away your rights and traditions and
way of life we're going to pressure the
companies too and we're going to
pressure the non-profit organizations
the ngos that have a lot of power around
the world and we're going to force them
all working together
conspiring you might say to pursue our
agenda the Davos agenda
the agenda of the Davos man that that
phrase has come into Vogue in recent
years the Davos man
the sort of person who doesn't feel any
particular local or national Allegiance
the Davos man who all he ever does is
works on his laptop he could work
anywhere in the world he feels far
greater camaraderie a far closer kinship
to the same sort of people who just Jet
Set all over the world and they they
mock things like patriotism they mock
things like tradition like our ordinary
way of life
like having a family like like being
rooted in a place they they mock that
that's not
for them
that's happening right now and so how
does this work in practice a lot of that
sounds kind of abstract well the way it
works in practice is right now the Davos
agenda is to make the rest of the world
look like China to make the West which
has a tradition of Freedom a tradition
rooted in Christianity a a tradition of
the most impressive civilization ever to
Grace the Earth
yeah that's all that's no good all that
freedom all those rights that you say
that you have that's really that's
that's hurting mother Gaia that's that's
uh provoking the sun monster to destroy
us all that's not giving these people
enough political power in Davos no no
you're a tradition of of political
Freedom where you have your
unrepresentative bodies and you make
your own laws for your own that's not
good you know increasingly globalized
world and so what what the wef has
suggested is that the model for the
future is the China Mountain what's the
China model you don't have rights you
don't have freedom you don't have your
tradition you have constant surveillance
and the people at the tippy tippy top
tell you exactly what you do all of the
time that is in fact a bigger political
issue
than whatever the marginal tax rate is
in the United States and conservatives
are waking up to that fact and you were
seeing it reflected in our activism
you're seeing this right now in Idaho
you're seeing parents pushing back
against all these little tiny things
because for so long conservatives just
took it I said okay these crazy Libs
they they want their weird sexual agenda
in the Public Square they want their
parades they okay whatever who cares all
right they want to redefine marriage
okay who cares all right they want to
bring the drag queens into the schools
okay all right okay they want to let
boys go into the little girls room in
the elementary school okay I guess who
cares who cares who cares well if we
don't care about any of these things
then I guess we just don't care about
our politics and we've surrendered our
self-government fortunately parents are
standing up where spineless Republican
politicians have have failed to stand up
you're seeing this in the Caldwell
School District right now
there was an agenda item before the
school board it was called policy I mean
it still is called policy
3281 and it's a policy that would let
the boys go into the girls bathroom
among other aspects of the trans agenda
and what you saw occur at this school
board meeting was you saw the people
broadly pushing back against this and
one state senator in particular but a
representative of the political order
coming in pushing back as well against a
corrupt School Board
state senator Chris trachel stood up to
this school board with
a broad representation of his
constituents behind him standing up to
the people who want to trans the kids
you claim you want people to follow the
rules but you break the rules left and
right last month you allowed two people
all right
we will recess for 15 minutes
[Music]
I'm sorry we have asked you absolutely
know the protocol
you're not following protocol yourself
Madam chair I moved to adjourn
okay I have a motion to adjourn do I
have a second
I love this woman who's trying to run
the school board meeting she goes the
moment she gets pushed back she goes
okay I'm going to adjourn the meeting
I I don't want to have to answer these
questions I don't want to have to
explain the policy so I moved to adjourn
do I have a second
because you need you need someone to
Second your motion and nobody in the
room wants to do it do I have a second
and you hear the the parents in the
crowd they say no you don't have a
second answer the question stop
transiting our kids
and and this woman looks to her fellow
school board members do I have do I have
a second
and then there's this all this dead
signs finally someone second so much she
goes okay a second in the motion
we're journeying see ya bye-bye
absolute embarrassment so it's it's
important to see these things happen at
the local level it's important to shine
a light on these movements at the local
level because it is it is in those small
things where the rot can begin and it's
in those small tiny little things where
a a return to sanity can begin as well
where recovery can begin where a
restoration of our country can begin as
well the other reason I bring up this
clip is because conservatives are fond
of saying
politics is Downstream of culture
and if that means that conservatives
should take over Hollywood again
great I agree
and if that means conservatives should
produce great works of art that shape
one's mind and soul good and if that
means that conservatives should
I don't know should conservatives start
exercising some control over education
that's cultural to a degree but now
we're starting to get a little bit
political isn't it because the
government has a say over education
and if if a state senator wants to show
up to a local school board and with a
group of parents is that cultural or is
that political I have long been
skeptical of this phrase politics is
Downstream of culture
because
not because it isn't true in the sense
that we need to make movies but because
I think it lets Republican politicians
off the hook
I think it is a kind of libertarian cope
to say the government is always bad the
government can never do anything right
so we just need people outside of the
government to do everything for us
it's a way to say okay we're going to
surrender the entire political order but
we live in a republic we live in
self-government
so in self-government in all states but
especially in self-government
the distinction between the culture and
the politics is pretty blurry because
it's we the people are supposed to be
doing both of those things what was that
meeting last night what was that episode
was that culture or was that politics I
bet that a ton of those people probably
probably every single person in that
room saw the daily wire Loudoun County
story where we exposed what happens when
boys are allowed to go into the girls
room and it can result in rapes and all
sorts of cover-ups and just terrible
disorder I bet you most people in that
room saw Matt's movie what is a woman
which exposed a lot of the transgender I
bet they've been following a lot of
cultural outlets on this question sure
but there's a state senator there and
the people would not have been nearly as
effective if the state senator had not
come in as well
and it's the people fighting against a
political body and what they're trying
to do is get a law rate a school rule to
be shot down to change the way that the
school is going to conduct business
isn't that politics or culture
there's both it's both and conservatives
I think we've gotten the message this
was the thesis of my my book speechless
controlling words controlling Minds
which is still available for order and
selling like hotcakes really appreciate
that there we go a little light on the
Bell today but that's all right we'll
pick it up it's early in the morning all
the flights are grounded everything's
chaos we'll probably get the Bell a
little bit quicker next time I mention
speechless
guys come on where's the eye right okay
we got a
we'll try a little bit later in the show
regardless my point is that I think
conservatives have gotten the message in
recent years that there's nothing wrong
with wielding the government within just
limits for good ends there's nothing
wrong with that we have to do that
otherwise we're surrendering not just
our politics but our whole culture we're
surrendering the whole country to the
libs and that's not going to turn out
very well because very very quickly the
the political predations of the libs are
going to go from hiking our taxes a
little bit and kind of putting some
annoying regulations on us to transiting
our kids it's going to go it's happening
very very quickly it's happening before
our very eyes you've got to become a
member of daily wire so head on over
dailywire.com Knowles
use code nulls at checkout yet two
months free
on all annual plans we will see you at
the member block
[Music]
[Music]